well hey there so I'm back today with
another reaction segment which is where
I basically give you my two cents in
response to videos submitted by you the
viewer today it's going to be a video by
Matt Whitman from the 10-minute Bible
Hour who a few years ago interviewed
three Adventists to learn what the
Seventh Adventist Church teaches and
believes but before we get into it if
you like what we're doing here and you
want to support us consider becoming a
channel member you will gain access to
our growing Library of members only
content including members only live
streams to join simply click the join
button down below this video or visit
our Channel homepage like you see on
screen where you'll find the same one
I'm truly grateful for all of our
supporters as this is absolutely a team
effort so thank you thank you thank you
for your support with that said I really
like Matt's videos so I'm curious to
listen in and see how it goes let's get
into
it is there a specific type of ESET
ology I mean a view of the end times
that is specifically Adventist or is it
just the idea Jesus is coming back I
think the Adventist thing came out of we
were born out of the millerite movement
and so there was this thought in the in
the early 1800s that Christ was going to
return soon like within every everyone
tried to set a date in fact they set
several dates and and there would be
this great expectation this was going to
happen and then they finally settled on
a date in
1844 and it didn't happen and and the
result of that is actually where our
denomination was born was they sat
around and they
said okay what happened what' we get
wrong and they started looking at what
they really believed but they what they
decided on was they still really
believed that Jesus was going to come
soon there was something that they were
reading in the Bible the timelines and
prophecy and everything else like that
was that you look at the course of
history and the the events that have
happened and you can look at the the
dates if you pull out of Daniel and of
Revelation that something is happening
very soon we think Christ is coming back
soon and so that's where the Adventist
part comes out of that all right so
these are the uh Happy Valley Pacific
Northwest sdas that Embrace a uh a
repackaged and reimagined version of
adventism what I call Neo adventism so
this should be interesting but that was
a pretty basic standard rundown I would
obviously disagree with the framing of
SDA history and I don't think that comes
as a shock to anybody if you've been
listening for any length of time I also
understand he's trying to be as succinct
as possible and have some brevity but
you'll notice he didn't actually say
that they were born out of multiple
failed prophecies or that some of their
key doctrines were formulated as
responses to failed prophecies he simply
highlighted that there were multiple
false dates that were set by various
individuals now we'll see if this comes
up later but Matt asked him if there's a
specific eschatology to adventism Matt
great question now it's almost become
routine to show this article every week
but here we are again when speaking
about the unique Adventist worldview the
great controversy theme notice one thing
that the late SDA Theologian Herbert
Douglas points out quote the aous
eschatological framework sets us apart
from every other denomination that
speaks of the end of the world because
it is governed by the great controversy
theme the distinctly Adventist view is
formed by a mutually supportive cluster
of ideas including conditional
immortality 7th Day sabari anism a
premillennial historicist eschatology
acceptance of the gift of Prophecy in
the ministry of Ellen White teachings
about the Priestly work of Christ in the
Heavenly sanctuary and a prepared people
by his grace this mutually supportive
cluster of ideas that marks Adventist
eschatology exists today because the
great controversy theme informs all
areas of Adventist thought now
Adventists can B and scoff at Douglas
all they want but that is one of the
foremost theologians this movement has
ever produced he understood the system
and wrote a book on this specific
subject called the heartbeat of
adventism it's still in PR Pacific press
is still printing copies of it and
selling it so to answer Matt's question
yes adventism does have a specific
eschatology and it isn't just standard
fair historicist premillennialism either
Advent eschatology is a part of the lens
in which the whole Bible is read and
we've looked at this from countless SDA
leaders before where they point to
things like Cain and Abel when talking
about the mark of the beast to say that
Cain being marked was foreshadowing the
end times
because he worshiped wrongfully he
worshiped in a way that wasn't pleasing
to God so he received a mark and that's
going to be like the people at the end
of time like Protestants and Roman
Catholics who are worshiping God in a
false way type thing or First Kings 18
where Ahab and Jezebel are used to say
that's a picture of apostate Protestant
uh protestantism linking up with Roman
Catholicism and the SDA church is
pictured by Elijah trying to repair the
breach and call Christians out of
spiritual ble
idolatry and all this stuff but really
at the top of all of that is the great
controversy theme and as Herbert Douglas
points out it's the GCT that functions
as the glue in their mutually supportive
cluster of doctrines if one Falls the
cluster falls apart it is the great
controversy theme that keeps them bound
together one has to interpret everything
through that framework to really
understand what SDA theology proper is
teaching which is why you're going to
always hear me going back to the great
controversy theme and examining
Adventist Doctrine in light of that
without that adventism loses its
Savor it's why they have to be held to
account on that level so 1844 at that
point you're not really Seventh Day
Adventist yet because the seventh day
thing hasn't happened yet we were part
of the millerite movement where people
believed there were people all over the
country thought that Christ was coming
at this time they sold their businesses
and their houses and everything a lot of
them went up their RS and expected this
great event this miraculous event to
happen we kind of refer to it as
internally as the great disappointment
but people externally refer to it as
that yeah really Advent sth day
adventism was born out of the the the
the Deep heartbreak and the questions
that people ask them afterwards like
this what what can what sense can we
make out of this could people go to your
church say the Apostles Creed or do you
guys think something different than that
and you won't find actually the concept
of creed within adventism and um it's
not it's not that there would be a
denial of the Apostles Creed um okay I
actually I actually you know find
resonation with
that oh brother yes there would be a
denial of the Apostles Creed in
adventism let's just get that out of the
way up front and I got to tell you it
drives me bonkers when Adventists do
this I'm sure this guy's nice don't have
a clue who he is personally but this
talking point is very easily falsified
and it's not truthful this guy he might
be ignorant on this I'm not sure but
it's not true I like how Matt asks this
because the Apostles Creed is the most
ancient statement of fundamental
biblical Christian teaching so it seems
like right out of the gate he's trying
to find out if adventism is
fundamentally Christian but one simple
evidence that an Adventist cannot affirm
the Apostles Creed is that they can't
affirm the communion of saints not in
any sense of the belief Adventists do
not believe that the believer who has
died joins the host of Heaven and that
when we commune every Sunday we're
worshiping with the church in heaven and
on Earth furthermore they don't they
don't commune with the Christian Church
they don't affirm that there is one holy
Universal Body of Christ they claim that
the actual one body of Christ is
apostate and they as the end times
Remnant are called out and separate from
that they think our corporate Worship On
the first day is an Abomination before
God and will eventually be involved in
the market the Beast and this doesn't
even get into the fact that the aous
Heavenly Trio is not the Trinity as I've
shown over and over and over elsewhere
but the Apostles Creed is a
christocentric and orthodoxly
trinitarian
statement the SDA Church rejects
Orthodox trinitarianism as I've also
shown numerous times before which would
mean the father son and spirit mentioned
in the Creed are not the father son and
spirit of adventism take for example
this statement in the SDA Church's
publication signs of the times from
19111 when describing the ainst Jesus
becoming Michael the Archangel in the
great controversy they write quote the
Eternal Word gave himself he did not
aspire to be equal with God did not
meditate a usurpation of the Throne of
the universe but he emptied himself gave
himself then and there for Sinners he
took the form of a servant becoming an
angel among the angels that he might
redeem Angels but they would not and
when they rejected the righteousness and
life so freely offered he descended
lower still to those duped by Satan
Fallen man stooping even to death that
he might redeem of the Fallen all who
desired to be redeemed and vindicate to
the universe to all eternity the
character of God that was the work of
the word of God the Eternal logos when
he became Michael the Archangel when he
became Jesus the man of Nazareth when he
was anointed the Christ when he died our
sacrifice on Calvary yet during all this
time the host of evil with all the
baleful deceptive cruel devices of sin
were hurled against him that God's
character might be marred that the great
Vindicator Redeemer might fall close
quote Yeah most certainly not the Jesus
of the Apostles Creed a Jesus who took
on an angel nature to try and save the
apostate angels that rebelled with Satan
but they rejected him so then he became
a man to try and save humans the Jesus
of scripture which is the Jesus of the
Creed doesn't have an Angelic nature
when some SDA say that the Adventist
Church has only ever taught that Jesus
is an Angel is uh in the sense of a
messenger no this proves that is
incorrect they claimed he as an Angelic
nature and I've shown multiple
statements on this not just this
one he Jesus Took the nature of angels
to repeat the first step then in his
humiliation in laying aside his divine
nature was to put on the nature of
angels and thus it is that we have Jesus
brought to view as Michael the Archangel
the commander of the hosts of Heaven the
captain of the host of the Lord and as
such the the armies in heaven follow him
when he became an angel he bore A
fitting name even as when later he
became a man his name befitted the
nature which he took by virtue of his
birth into our human family that name
was Emmanuel God With Us his name as an
angel is Michael which signifies the one
who is like God but also notice another
thing herb Douglas tells us back in that
Ministry magazine article quote how we
understand this Core theme directly
effects how we grasp the intent of
biblical writers when they used words
such as righteousness salvation gospel
Etc the great controversy theme helps us
to work our way through centuries of
theological confusion over the meaning
of such realities as justification
sanctification atonement obedience and
works without the GCT all would remain
divided over such subjects as the
importance of the Old Testament
Sanctuary service and the New Testament
view of Christ as our high priest me
mediator the meaning of faith and Grace
the place of obedience in relation to
legalism why Jesus came the first time
why he came the way he did and when he
will return close quote which would mean
that the Apostles Creed would be
filtered through the great controversy
Paradigm which would do the interpreting
of the doctrinal statements that it
makes while Protestants Catholics
Orthodox Etc may have differences at a
granular level on some of the things
within we don't bring an extra biblical
worldview to the Creed that serves as a
seminal governing principle point being
no an Adventist that upholds and
believes official Seventh Adventist
teaching cannot affirm the Apostles
Creed there the early Adventist mindset
was a very strong anti-realism so
there's a wide tolerance within
Adventist thought and it's frustrating
because like we can go into an Adventist
bookstore and buy two books by Adventist
authors and sometimes published in an
Adventist Publishing House your own book
stories that yeah Christian bookstore
adven Christian bookstore is something
that you'll see but the thing that's
frustrating sometimes is that you can
find completely
opposing um ideas you know published and
there's this Toleration and this this
and it's really frustrating sometimes
but it's also really like a sense of
like deep take a deep breath and feel
the a sense of freedom and openness to
be basically pursue truth in the word of
God so I love how Matt was like wait you
guys have your own bookstores yes and
Matt they also have their own canned soy
meat products it's one of those things
that you don't really stop to think
about when you're in the avenus bubble
but after you leave and stop to think
about you're like well you know it's
kind of strange they this religious
institution has their their own fake
meat products that they pedal in
conjunction with their health message
that's just as unhealthy for you as the
fake meat is and before an aous clips
that yes I know the food companies and
manufacturers aren't owned by the SDA
Church Corporation but you know what I
mean but what's more startling about
this exchange was hearing how the Neo
Adventists have a totally foreign
mindset regarding doctrinal unity and
it's one that doesn't jive with their
own fundamental beliefs in the Adventist
Bel fundamental beliefs book which is
the official exposition of their
fundamental beliefs in the chapter on
Unity we read this under the heading of
unity of faith quote diversity of
spiritual gifts does not mean A
diversity of beliefs however in the last
days God's church will be composed of
people who share a common platform of
the Everlasting gospel their lives
characterized by the observance of The
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus Revelation 24:12 together they
Proclaim to the world God's invitation
to Salvation close quote furthermore in
the chapter on Ellen White they speak of
how the prophetic gift in the New
Testament is supposed to function they
list six ways and one of them is that
it's supposed to unite and protect the
church quote prophets help to bring
about the unity of the faith protect the
church against false doctrines so
Believers would no longer be infants
tossed back and forth by the waves and
blown here and there by every wind of
teaching and by the cunning and
craftiness of people in their deceitful
scheming so adventism isn't supposed to
have this wide spectrum of beliefs
they're supposed to be United in ways
that no one else is because they have
God uniquely with them speaking through
the writings of Ellen White to navigate
them through the Perils of the end
times the gentleman in this interview
presented his own flavor of adventism
trying to make it sound like the gold
standard yet it wasn't even in
accordance with the fundamental
beliefs Everlasting gospel and adventism
folks is just a euphemism for the aous
system of
theology yet those tend to be the most
divisive doctrines within the movement
the
pillars you you can't get them to agree
on the investigative judgment the health
message that's why trying to do the
whole adventism is a big tent thing to
try and appear a certain way to
Outsiders it's it's actually a
self-inflicting wound because it
undermines their own fundamental beliefs
which are an actual formal
representative for adventism not these
individuals what they're putting forward
would classify adventism as Babylon
according to their own authoritative
sources a doctrinally confused mess of
inconsistencies and as time goes on some
within the movement in an attempt to
better prze Christians and build inroads
with Protestants and evangelicals have
sought to take this big tent approach to
try and make adventism seem like
something that it's
not the Neo Adventists have just tried
to Rebrand the system but at the end of
the day the Seventh Adventist
organization is simply a corporation
selling a product the great controversy
theme that's their product people are
recruited and encouraged to spread the
material and the ideology of that
worldview to the rest of the world
making more people coming into the
organization most Adventists are
well-meaning people I say this a lot I
have tons of excellent memories as an
Adventist love Adventist people it's why
this platform exists despite the
mountain of them that you know hate this
effort but at the end of the day that's
what this system is about when you boil
it down to its Court Adventists are
obviously going to disagree with me on
that but he who has eyes to see let him
see but at the same time you guess have
a statement of faith that has 28
articles 2 beliefs so fundamental
beliefs I apologize um so so we're not
opposed to systematizing like we're
willing to try to boil it down to a
degree what's the difference between
having arum when our church founded was
some people said should we organize or
should we not organize are we going
against everything that we believe by
actually organizing because we're here
about seeking truth and learning and
growing will we be confining ourselves
if we actually organize as a
denomination and they realized they
pretty they that they needed to have
that level of organization which then
helped us grow once we you know very
quickly help me understand the the
difference between a Creed and a a 28
articles I'm not getting wrong yet 28
Bel and 28 fundamental beliefs how is
that not a Creed what's the difference
between the two ideas I think within the
fundamental beliefs there's an
understanding that the language can be
updated as as clarification happens like
you know there there's sometimes
languaging that you know maybe at the
founding of our church wasn't as helpful
and and today we would just communicate
a similar idea differently okay AKA they
believe in what they call present truth
notice for example what SDA historian
George Knight notes about present truth
quote Joseph Bates and James and Ellen
White the three founders of seventh day
adventism each had a dynamic concept of
what they called present truth the use
of that term wasn't unique to them the
millerites earlier had employed it to
refer to the imminent return of Jesus
later they applied it to the seven-month
movement the proclamation in the Autumn
of 1844 that the second Advent would
take place on October 22nd of that year
thus even in the millerite use of the
term present truth we find a progressive
Dynamic understanding close quote right
a dynamic concept that essentially
functions like a magic wand anytime they
need to get out of a pickle they simply
employ present truth and magically the
problem is fixed supposedly it really
operates more like relative Truth For
example historically speaking it was
present truth in 1849 to believe that
the time of trouble would be in that
year in the very first volume of present
truth which was a millerite publication
Ellen White's husband James White writes
in Peter's time there was present truth
or truth applicable to that present time
the church has ever had present truth
the present truth now is that which
shows present Duty and the right
position for us who were about to
witness the time of trouble such as
never was present truth must be of
repeated even to those who are
established in it this was needful in
the apostles day and it certainly is no
less important for us who are living
just before the close of time close
quote so it was present truth to believe
that the time of trouble at the end of
the world was going to begin that year
and your conscience was to be bound to
that but it didn't come about and
present truth changed somehow the errant
belief can still rightly be called Truth
makes total sense right now of course
Adventists love to distance themselves
from this and try and stick with only
1863 and onward which was when the
organization Incorporated but the point
is that truth is part of the reason for
the mass confusion within adventism and
it's the root as to why the movement is
anti-al and for those that want to see
the sources and more on this there's a
link to this article from our website in
the description box down below but I
noticed that Justin coup mentioned the
uh it's not a Creed because it can be
updated talking point but he also said
this is because they grow as
clarification happens and they would
communicate a similar idea differently
sometimes that's true but other times
it's done to allow for plausible
deniability such as when they updated
fundamental belief number 18 regarding
Ellen White are we really to believe
that the SDA Church doesn't still
believe that Ellen White is a continuing
and authoritative source of Truth they
still mean the same thing by saying she
carries prophetic Authority so Matt to
answer your question their beliefs are
slippery that's how I would describe
them between what you were told about
the bookstore and doctrinal confusion
then you add present truth into the mix
yeah recipe for
disaster so with with those 28
statements you've got the ability to
really nuance and I mean I've read them
and
frankly that gets into stuff I've never
seen in a doctrinal statement not that I
necessarily think is like unchristian or
disagree with it's just there's stuff
that wow that's incredibly specific to
make like the top 28 list that's really
specific and it didn't start in 28 but
it's grown it's grown okay the push back
against creedalism is the sense of like
let's let's reject uh uh setting
ourselves in concrete in such a way
where like if we came back and together
as a church said you know what guys
we've been wrong about this or we we we
we didn't see this in scripture before
and there's a sense of like again that
emphasis on present truth see told you
is there anything actually in the Creeds
that you guys just historically have
always been like yeah yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes is there anything that you
would say you just don't agree with
about the three big ones I can say the
apostles
and um while I may have like some some
uh some different theological
understandings that underpin some of
that like um for instance the the state
of man in death um and so uh and
reference to hell for instance like I
may understand some of those things
differently but like to me that isn't a
bar to be able to say like well I can't
participate in Christian Fellowship
because of this so you would Nuance the
language like a Protestant might say
well by you know the one universal
Catholic Church what we mean by that
language Church Catholic or I know some
Protestants would say yeah we're
definitely credal Christians we're not
quite sure on the language of descended
into hell um and I might like to just
make a comment on that right well I
could say this I might like to so would
that be where you you land on this
exactly okay right the Apostles Creed
would be read in light of the great
controversy Paradigm which would mean
you don't believe the Creed it's one
thing to have Nuance it's another thing
to completely filter the Creed through
an extra biblical worldview that isn't
derived from scripture but was allegedly
uniquely given to the SDA Church by God
himself through a woman in the 19th
century that would have classifi those
behind the Apostles Creed the framers of
that Creed to be false convert Pagan
Christians for not being 7even day
sabbatarians from her book gospel
workers which is instructions for those
proclaiming the SDA message Ellen White
states that God instructed her to say
quote gather from the scriptures the
proofs that God has Sanctified the
seventh day and let those proofs be read
before the congregation let those who
have not heard the truth be shown that
all who turn aside from a plain thus
sayeth the Lord must suffer the result
of their course in all ages the Sabbath
has been the test of loyalty to God it
is a sign between me and the children of
Israel forever the Lord declares close
close quote the Christians behind the
Apostles Creed were not ignorant of 7th
Day sabbatarianism and outright rejected
it and since it was apparently a test of
loyalty to God in all ages the framers
of the Creed were apparently not loyal
to God this coming from someone who has
more Authority in adventism than any of
the gentlemen sitting at the table with
Matt
Whitman I think that this is the reason
why we prefer the fundamental belief
approach as opposed to a Creed because
you know even within the Creed itself
like on things like the what happens
when you die and the nature of hell like
for us there is a different like we mean
something different than when I think
the average Christian describes what
hell is or what happens after you die
and so for us that that nuancing in our
language of the fundamental belief is
only possible because we don't actually
hold to oh like a Verbatim
Creed right like I said they would
filter it all through the great
controversy theme and they don't mean
the same thing that Christians do Justin
thank you for admitting this even if it
was in a very obfuscatory way well let
me ask you about that then what what is
nuanced about the whole death and Hell
thing for you guys I believe that
scripture teaches that when I die my
body stops working and I believe in the
unity I believe scripture teaches the
unity of body and breath and that
there's not an immortal spirit that like
goes somewhere like when I die I die and
I'm in and and I see death in scripture
as asleep and that there is a bodily
resurrection that happens when Jesus
comes back and that the dead are
resurrected so we see death as asleep so
we don't believe that your soul goes
immediately to heaven or to hell um for
Eternal Bliss or eternal torment when
you when you die okay now he said we
signifying that means Adventist believe
what he said well this is another area
that disqualifies a by the book
believing Adventist from being able to
affirm the Apostles Creed and no it
isn't the line that Jesus descended into
hell the Apostles Creed clearly states
that Christians believe in the
resurrection of the body and the life
Everlasting to which one would say right
and Adventist believe in the
resurrection though so what's the big
deal incorrect as the SDA Bible
commentary states which quotes from
Ellen White's book Heaven quote our
personal identity is preserved in the
resurrection though not the same
particles of matter or material
substance as went into the grave the
wondrous works of God are a mystery to
man The Spirit the character of man is
return to God there to be preserved in
the resurrection every man will have his
own character God in his own time will
call forth the dead giving again the
breath of life and bidding the dry bones
live the same form will come forth but
it will be free from disease and every
defect it lives again bearing the same
individuality of features so that friend
will recognize friend there is no law of
God in nature which shows that God gives
back the same identical particles of
matter which composed the body before
death God shall give the righteous dead
a body that will please him close quote
this is to say that the SDA Church
doesn't teach that the self-same body
that one died in will be raised rather a
new body of new particles will be formed
and since you don't exist in any way
shape or form Beyond physical death your
character and personality is retained in
the mind of The avenus God Who will
Infuse that personality into a new body
thus that's supposed to be what
Christians believe about Resurrection
except absolutely not and that is a
resurrection that is more like a cloning
in 1 Corinthians 15 Paul uses the Lord
Jesus Christ as his example for what the
believer will one day experience Jesus
resurrected in the self-same body that
he died in and in verse 42 he clearly
says that what is sown is then raised a
new body of new particles was never sown
to then be raised now maybe that
gentleman's happy to disagree with the
SDA Bible commentary and his prophetess
but they hold far more Authority when it
comes to representing official SDA
teaching the point being a card carrying
Adventist does not affirm biblical
Resurrection which is what is meant and
encapsulated in the apostles Greek and
then connected with that is our our view
about hell and the destruction of the
wicked we believe in annihilationism so
we believe that there will be the world
will be and and evil will be destroyed
by fire that will be permanent and it
will not be ongoing forever forever in
that context um we understand to be for
as long as a person lives so um we do
believe in in hell but our concept of
hell is not a place of eternal torment
it uh because I mean quite frankly I see
that as inconsistent with the character
of the god of scripture even the
destruction of the wicked is is
characterized by scripture as like God's
strange act yeah no now folks I'm not an
apologist for hell it's not something I
just sit around and salivate over and
constantly talk about but one of the
first big triggers for me when leaving
adventism with regards to my view of
Hell shifting was realizing that I'm not
the judge of God I'm not the judge as to
whether or not he is or isn't loving
just fair
Etc what this guy said is something I've
heard countless adventus say the sort of
well my God would never do that type
response I've heard that from lots of
people by the way not just Adventists
well the true God's not on trial like
the Adventist
God the one true God is Not only loving
if you deem him to be this is the great
controversy worldview rearing its head
again with the idea that God is on trial
and needs Vindicated from accusations
made by Satan which is nowhere found in
the Bible he he's appealing to you know
God's strange act that's being pulled
from Isaiah 28 and it's what Ellen White
pulled from to say the same thing except
if you read that in any modern
translation you're going to clearly see
Isaiah wasn't saying what was just
conveyed that the condemnation of the
wicked is some strange foreign sort of
thing that God has to do even though he
doesn't want to folks just read Proverbs
I want to get back to the history thing
just a little bit before we move on from
it what happened in the 20 years between
the great disappointment and was it 1863
that that formalization occurred 19
years so what happened in there and how
did we get to a place where we are a
denomination a lot of soul searching
okay a lot of a lot of reading of the
Bible first thing was like what did we
get
wrong what happened um we being the
millerites yeah the Miller yeah and a
lot of people left the movie right and
what did you find that you got
wrong well before we get there uh yeah
put a pin but I mean this is all
connected there were the answers to
those
questions um were different for
different groups of people some people
said everything that Miller taught was
just like garbage threw the whole thing
out walked away from Faith altogether a
missed prophecy does have that effect
Absolut and you could even make an Old
Testament case that you miss one
prophecy like that and well it would be
courteous to just walk away yeah yeah
there were others who who said Miller
was right about the fact that the coming
of Christ was soon but he he understood
the he understood the whole 1844 thing
wrong that's where Adventists would find
themselves um in that in that place of
going like okay so um even within that
there was this sense of like nothing
happened in 18 1944 guys that was
another another way of interpreting it
but the the group of Adventist milite
people who who who came to the place
that they said actually something
happened but we got it wrong what it was
that was the group that eventually kind
of coalesced and eventually became that
nucleus became Seventh Day Adventist but
they still didn't have the Sabbath or
seventh day sorry I might have cut you
off all right so the subject that many
don't like to talk about what I call the
Forgotten years 1844 to 63 and Matt was
right the biblical standard is if a
false prophet gives even one false
prophecy don't listen to that individual
ignore them the SDA church has sought to
Rebrand William Miller as an American
reformer in an article on our website I
write quote the SDA Church regularly
touts that the founder of millerism
William Miller was an American reformer
this is typically to wax over the fact
that he was a false prophet who errone
ly dates set the return of Christ in
1843 since the SDA church is a daughter
of millerism with roots tied back to his
biblical interpretation methods and
historical claims they have to try and
reposition William Miller in a favorable
light The Fountain Head for this
assertion is coming from their
prophetess Len G white who they believe
was divinely inspired and corrects
inaccurate interpretations of scripture
and this is basically what this
gentleman was getting at by saying that
instead of just throwing all the Miller
out some people sought to find meaning
in the great disappointment these people
essentially refused to to believe they
were wrong which is still the
disposition of the SDA Church to this
day American reformer is an interesting
way of saying false prophet this is
obviously why the organization has
sought to Rebrand him but it must be
stated clearly and emphatically the
response to 1844 was born out of a
supposed Vision given to HRA medson in a
cornfield the day after the great
disappointment it did not come from or
start with bible study this is a fact
this Vision was then used to search the
Bible to try and find meaning in the
disappointment and this gentleman leaves
this glaring pivotal fact off as SDA
Theologian P Gerard dski documents in a
paper he wrote titled how our Pioneers
discovered the sanctuary Doctrine he
writes quote after their sweet Advent
experience the crushing blow of Jesus's
non-appearance caused many to give up
their belief that prophetic time was
fulfilled and others to give up their
Christian experience altogether still
others however remained faithful to
their earlier convictions they felt that
it was the Lord who had led them thus
far and he would give them light to
solve their biblical and spiritual
perplexities they were convinced that
more study of the word of God would
bring the solution in time the results
of this Earnest Quest For Truth proved
very revealing and deeply satisfying the
Adventist daily searching and praying
was not in vain beginning with h medson
remarkable experience of perception
regarding Christ Sanctuary Ministry on
the very morning of their disappointment
they went on to discover in the Bible
amazing light that gave them strength
comfort and profound insights into
Christ's closing work for the Salvation
of humanity close quote so that's the
Fuller explanation of what actually
happened after the disappointment not
just that people refused to give up and
they went to their Bibles and studied
like crazy as D notes it began with
higher medson alleged Vision which was
then believed to be true and brought to
the Bible to try and see how they could
make it fit but even D tried to
frontload the statement by saying all
their prayer and searching wasn't in
vain making it seem like some big window
of time elapsed but no it was the day
immediately after the disappointment
less than 24 hours later and this Vision
was the Bedrock for what formally
developed into the investigative
judgment which is only one of the steps
out of seven regarding their very
elaborate Sanctuary model of Salvation
it was further cemented into the
movement by another Vision this time
from Ellen White on April 21st 1847 she
wrote quote I believe the sanctuary to
be cleansed at the end of the 2300 days
is the New Jerusalem Temple of which
Christ is a minister the Lord Shu me EnV
Vision more than one year ago that
brother croiser had the true light on
the cleansing of the sanctuary and that
it was his will that brother C should
write out the view which he gave us in
the dayar extra February 7 1846 I feel
fully authorized by the Lord to
recommend that extra to every saint
close quote what really came out of the
great disappointment that's not being
mentioned is that there is allegedly an
entirely new way to be made right with
God because that's what the Seventh Day
Adventist doctrine of the sanctuary is
about following the Adventist Jesus is
done by following him through the
sanctuary leading you down the seven
steps but I didn't expect them to get
into all this let alone all the other
chicanery and lenti behavior that
occurred during the Forgotten years
maybe they will let's see that's all
right but it was in that searching
moment that they started looking at the
whole Bible and saying because they were
so focused on Prophecy and the second
coming they started then pouring through
the whole Bible and saying okay what
else did we get wrong or what else do we
have to look at and that's when the
Sabbath came out of that they they they
um and our health doctor and other
things like
that yeah again this is a convenient way
of framing it but not entirely
forthright like we just saw the
searching moment began with an alleged
Vision in a cornfield the day
immediately after the great
disappointment this became the escape
hatch to not accept that they were wrong
and shouldn't have been listening to and
following a false prophet
they shouldn't have been condemning all
the other actual Christian churches as
apostate like people like Charles Fitch
were doing preaching damnation on all
these people they should have humbled
themselves and admitted that they
weren't smarter than everyone else they
didn't study harder than everyone else
they got duped and I get it folks I've
studied the great disappointment a lot
people were committing suicide people
genuinely believed this it was a harsh
go at it it's not like in the modern day
where we have a lot of safety net type
things
people didn't Farm their crop I mean it
was a whole thing but this is why people
need to heed the word of God Miller was
in explicit violation of the word of God
by setting dates the reason the majority
of Christians didn't join Miller was
because they had Godly discernment and
followed the biblical counsel to not
listen to people like
that you know Ellen White tried to
Rebrand this as well millerites were
trying to spread millerism to the
churches and we were booted out because
they didn't they rejected this literal
second coming no you were booted out for
trying to spread date setting which is
in stark contrast to what the Bible
tells you to do and it isn't just that
they supposedly rediscovered what the
bible really teaches about the Sabbath
Visions from Ellen White added all sorts
of Novelties to the doctrine of the
Sabbath which play a larger role in the
great controversy
worldview in the same publication we
looked at earlier the present truth
August 1st 1849 this time Ellen White
writes quote I I saw that the present
test on the Sabbath could not come until
the mediation of Jesus in the Holy place
was finished and he had passed within
the second Veil therefore Christians who
fell asleep before the door was opened
in the most holy when the Midnight Cry
was finished at the 7th month 1844 and
had not kept the true Sabbath now Rest
In Hope for they had not the light and
the test on the Sabbath which we now
have since that door has opened close
quote so out of the sanctuary comes the
Sabbath which is supposedly a great test
and and a present test that couldn't
come until Jesus had entered into the
most holy place in 1844 so unlike the
7th Day Baptist who influenced the early
millerites the sabbatarian Adventists
believed that the Sabbath was a test of
loyalty to God but only beginning with
the little flock anyone before them
rested in Hope because they didn't have
the light and test on the Sabbath but
like we saw earlier what's fascinating
about this is in the final year of her
life 1915 she claimed that the Sabbath
was a test in all
generations and let's also not forget
the holy kiss which was also a supposed
test with God in early writings Ellen
White documents one of her Visions about
events she said were to come in the
future before the return of Christ she
writes the 144,000 were all sealed and
perfectly United on their foreheads was
written God New Jerusalem and a glorious
star containing Jesus's new name at our
happy holy State the wicked were enraged
and would rush violently up to lay hands
on us to th trust us into prison when we
would stretch forth the hand in the name
of the Lord and they would fall helpless
to the ground then it was that the
synagogue of Satan knew that God had
loved us who could wash one another's
feet and salute the Brethren with a holy
kiss and they woried at our feet close
quote this is to say that one of the
identifying marks of the true followers
of God in the end times was to be that
they practiced foot washing and the holy
kiss but fast forward to 1957 in the SDA
publication the the youth's instructor
the question is asked as to why they
don't practice the holy kiss if it's
commanded by Paul to which the answer is
given quote there is no evidence in
these injunctions that they were to have
Universal application to the church till
the end of time they were based on local
custom and though the principle of
Brotherly Love and Affection still
applies the custom has long since fallen
into
disuse close
quote which would mean that Ellen White
didn't have a vision of the people of
God at the end of time after all and the
same is true with the health message all
of the abous pillar doctrines are
cemented into the movement by visions
which bring with them all sorts of
supposed inspired details that are not
found in the Bible but are coming from
God so they may as well be equal with
the Bible I know the SDA church and
Adventists are going to say no no no
folks practically speaking it's not
different they're both coming from the
same Source God is Not fallible it's
coming from the same Source that's the
CL
again I didn't expect these gentlemen to
bring this stuff up but I guess my point
is Christian there's a lot more going on
here than what they're letting on
history is not the SDA Church's friend
especially not the forgotten
years now we'll pick up on the rest of
this in part two but like I mentioned at
the start this is sort of what I
expected the Neo Adventist presentation
of adventism is always this rebranded
effort to try and make it seem like
something different than what it
fundamentally is anyways if you like
what we're doing here smash that like
button and subscribe so that you can can
be updated next time we go live and
until next time May Christ richly bless
you in the grace and peace won by him
and his vicarious death on the cross for
Sinners Hallelujah
May oh
apostate did he say
that come on man
[Music]